[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Mobile users
expect their apps
to have beautiful designs,
smooth animations,
and great performance.
To deliver on this,
developers need
to create new features faster
than ever without compromising
on quality or performance.
That's why we built Flutter.
Flutter is Google's
mobile UI framework
that provides a fast and
expressive way for developers
to build native apps on
both iOS and Android.
This is because apps and
interfaces made with Flutter
are built from a single
codebase, compiled directly
to native arm code, use the GPU,
and can access platform APIs
and services.
Here are three ways that Flutter
will help you on day one.
Flutter is engineered for
high developer velocity.
Stateful hot reload allows
you to change your code
and see it come to
life in less than a
second, without losing
the state of the app.
Flutter also ships
with a rich set
of customizable widgets, all
built from our modern reactive
framework.
Plus, Flutter integrates with
popular development tools,
which means you can get started
quickly with the editor or IDE
you already know and love.
Flutter moves the widgets,
rendering, animation,
and gestures into the framework,
to give you complete control
over every pixel on the screen.
This means you have flexibility
to build custom designs.
Flutter apps follow platform
conventions and interface
details, such as scrolling,
navigation, icons, fonts,
and more.
This is why apps
built with Flutter
are featured on both the App
Store and Google Play Store.
Flutter is great for developers,
both new and experienced
in mobile.
If you're new to mobile,
Flutter gives you
a fast, fun, and modern
way to deliver native apps.
If you're an experienced
mobile developer,
you can add Flutter to your
existing workflows and tools
to build new expressive UIs.
Flutter is free and
open source, and used
by developers and
organizations around the world,
including enterprise,
agencies, and startups.
Visit flutter.io to
get started today.
We can't wait to
see what you build.